apple's new a15 chip has been causing a
lot of confusion because this year they
decided not to compare it to the
previous a14 during their recent event
causing a lot of people to believe that
there are barely improvements at all
this year so i ended up watching some of
the other takes on youtube about what in
the world is going on with the a15 and
what it means for future chips like the
m1x and the m2 and i think a lot of
those other takes are missing some
important details but thankfully reviews
of the iphone 13 just came out and we
obviously got a massive improvement at
least with the 5 core gpu version of the
13 pro giving us as much as 14
437 metal graphics points which is much
faster than the a14 chip in the iphone
12. so i've been doing a bit of research
and i think i've actually figured out
exactly what the a15 chip is based on
which confirms many of my other theories
on the upcoming m1x chip and the future
m2 chat so before i get into explaining
my theory i want to point out a couple
of very important details that i found
about the a15 chips performance
benchmarks that led to this discovery
like i said before the 5 core gpu
version of the a15 was able to score a
huge improvement over the a14 and mr
who's the boss's recent tests however
the 4 core gpu version of the a15 scored
around 10
875 points which is very interesting
because it's the same 4 core gpu layout
as the a14 showing that there is around
a 16 improvement due to having faster or
a better course now this brought me to a
very interesting article by the apple
tree on twitter who examined the leaked
benchmarks that came out a few days ago
before these reviews were out and he
came up with some awesome conclusions he
looked at the cpu benchmarks and saw
that the a15 scores around 1720 in the
single core test which is around a 10
gain versus the a14 chip which scored
around 1570 points however the leaked
benchmarks for the multi-core
performance show a score of around 4 600
compared to 3 800 for the a14 which is
around an 18 to 19 percent improvement
now this doesn't really make sense
because the six core layout of the chip
stayed the same this year and the only
explanation is that the efficiency cores
themselves have gotten more powerful in
the a15 the apple tree did some
calculations and found that with the old
a14 ship the efficiency course combined
scored around 700 points so he applied
the same math to the leaked 815
multi-core score of 4600 and he
concluded that the efficiency cores
should now score around 1150 points by
themselves being around 60 faster year
over year and this is going to give us a
major benefit if the efficiency cores
are faster this means that they can
handle more tasks by themselves without
the performance course having to turn on
at all which is going to lead to major
battery life improvements now with that
said let's finally get into the
important realization that brings me to
my new theory on the a15 the newly
revealed single core benchmarks for the
a15 ship show a score of around 17 40
points with the performance core running
at 3.23 gigahertz clock speed and then i
realized that this number seems very
familiar so i looked at the benchmarks
of the m1 macbooks which scored around
17 14 to 17 21 points at a 3.2 gigahertz
clock speed which is almost identical so
here is my crazy theory what if apple
took the performance course from the m1
chip tweaked them up a bit by increasing
the clock speed by 0.03 gigahertz and
then tossed those cores into the a15
chip alongside some other changes like
doubling the system cache in the soc
that would actually explain why the
single core performance is just a tad
bit faster on the a15 than on the m1 and
if you really think about it the m1
cores are really just tweaked versions
of the a14 course now you might be
saying how is it possible for apple to
throw those insanely powerful
performance cores into the iphone
because obviously it's a much smaller
device so it heats up much more than a
macbook well unlike the m1 chip the a15
is built on tsmc's 5 nanometer plus
architecture so it's more efficient and
it doesn't heat up as much but then
there's also the question of why apple
would reuse the m1 performance course in
the first place instead of redesigning
brand new entirely different performance
cores well if you didn't already know
for the past decade or so apple's armed
cores have been based on the arm v8
architecture and earlier this year arm
has already announced rmv9 with some
massive improvements which apple will
definitely take advantage of but the
downside is that it won't be ready to
launch until next year so if you're in
apple shoes why would you spend time
redesigning the performance cores if
you're about to totally switch to the
new rv9 architecture by far the easiest
solution is to just take those same m1
cores tweak them up a little bit and
then toss them into the a15 chip
alongside some other new components
which i'm going to talk about in just a
second and to test this theory out i
ended up crunching a bunch of numbers to
see if everything matches up and spoiler
alert it does so let's get right into
that first off as we know the m1 chip
scores around 7 500 points and geekbench
5's multi-core test compared to the a15
chip's maximum score of 4874
and mr who's the boss's video we also
know that the m1 chip uses an 8 core
layout compared to 6 on the a15 so the
m1 essentially has two extra performance
cores we also know that the m1 chips
efficiency cores combined add around 700
points to the multi-core test due to
previous calculations we made when we
studied the m1 chair so if i grab the 7
500 multi-core score that we got with
our m1 macbooks and then minus 700 from
the efficiency course we're left with a
score of 6800 points between the m1's
for performance cores now divide that by
four and you get around 1700 points per
performance core so now with that said
let's try to recreate the a15 chip's six
core layout which includes two
performance cores and four efficiency
cores and see if it matches up to the
new iphone 13 pro max's score of
4874. first we take the 1700 points and
multiply it by two performance cores
giving us 3
400 points
now if we add in the 700 points from the
m1s for efficiency cores we have a new
score of 4100
which is definitely shy
774 points however we're forgetting the
most important detail according to the
apple tree the efficiency cores this
year are much faster so if we look at
the multi-core score of the 13 pro max
and we minus out the performance from
the two performance cores we're left
with
1376 points which are from the
efficiency cores alone so if we go back
and take the 3 400 points that we got
from the m1 chips performance cores and
then add 1376 points instead of 700 we
get a total multi-core score of 4776
points which is within a margin of error
from the a15 chip score that mr who's
the boss showed us on the iphone 13 pro
max but wait it gets even better because
i did the same thing for the gpu cores
as well when we benchmarked our m1
macbook pro with the 8 core gpu it
scored as much as 22 000 points in
geekbench 5's metal test and as we know
the a15 chip comes with either a 4 core
or a 5 core gpu so i took the 22 000
points from the m1 and divided it by 8
to get 2
750 points per gpu core and if we
multiply that number by 4 cores we get
11 000 metal points which almost
perfectly matches the metal score in the
regular iphone 13s 4 core gpu version of
the a15 chair and then if we apply that
same math to the five core version of
the a15 we get a score of around 13
750 points which is still shy of the 14
400 points from the new five core
versions benchmarks however if we go
back to the apple trees article he
pointed out that the gpu cores and the 5
core version of the a15 are actually
clocked slightly higher than the ones in
the 4 core version which would account
for the extra difference that we see
with the iphone 13 pro max but either
way the point that i'm trying to make is
that these scores in the a15 ship are
matching up so closely that we can
basically confirm that the a15 is almost
certainly using tweaked and improved
versions of the m1s cpu and gpu cores
with the biggest difference being the
much faster efficiency course now i'm
not trying to say that apple just took
the m1 cores and threw them into the a15
because obviously the efficiency cores
are much faster and the gpu cores are
clocked slightly higher on the 5 core
gpu version of the a15 but they're close
enough that we can assume apple just
tweaked up the cores from the a14 and
the m1 and if you really think about it
apple going with this approach of
tweaking the cores saves them a ton of
engineering cost having the a14 the m1
and a15 chips all using basically the
same fundamental cores but with
different tweaks to each one and if you
think i'm crazy i can actually prove
this by examining the latest ipad airs
a14 chip which uses the same four core
gpu layout as the lower end 4 core a15
chat surprisingly it actually scores as
much as 12 500 metal points in geekbench
5 which is higher than the 10
875 points that the iphone 13's newer
a15 chip is getting so somehow last
year's four core a14 ship is
outperforming the new four core a15
champ which doesn't seem to make any
sense at all but the truth is that
they're fundamentally the same cores but
apple just went all out with the
performance in the ipad air and they
ended up toning down the performance in
the new iphone 13 because it's a much
smaller device that doesn't handle heat
as well but making things even more
interesting if you take that 12 500
graphic score from the ipad air and then
double it to match the eight gpu cores
in the m1 chip it should score around 25
000 metal points but for some reason the
m1 ipad pro and the other m1 max only
score up to around 22 000 which means
that apple tuned down the performance
lower than what the chips are
technically capable of due to heat
management but with that said getting
back to the a15 chip of course we know
it's technically a newly designed chip
because it comes with new features like
a new image signal processor a new
display engine double the system cache a
new neural engine that's much faster
than before and new video encoders and
decoders but it seems like apple
combined whatever new components they
had with the tweaked versions of the a14
cores to create the a15 chip design
including the new super fast efficiency
course and with that theory explained
now let me get into how this perfectly
matches up to rumors of the m1 champ
mark german believes that the m1 chip
will come with a new 10 core layout with
eight performance cores instead of four
on the m1 but just two efficiency cores
instead of the previous four and if you
think it's weird for apple to ditch two
of the efficiency cores because it seems
like the battery life is at risk
remember that the new ones in the a15
chip are much faster and we're expecting
those same faster efficiency cores to
show up in the m1x chip and those faster
efficiency cores are going to be able to
handle more tasks by themselves without
having to turn on the performance cores
and that is going to save more battery
life so with that said everything points
to the m1x chip being based on the cores
from the m1 and a15 chips and if this is
true here are some conservative
estimates for the performance i'm
expecting from the m1x and on top of
that apple is going to include the new
much faster 16 core neural engine from
the a15 chip into the m1x along with
anything else that might be new from the
a15 and then adding on mac exclusive
updates like changes to the thunderbolt
controller to allow more ports and
display outputs now as far as the future
m2 chip i personally believe that it's
going to be coming next year and it's
going to debut with the m2 redesigned
macbook air the biggest piece of
evidence for this conclusion is an
article from mark german claiming that
the redesigned macbook air would come
with an m2 chip that features the same
amount of cpu cores as the m1 but with
two additional gpu cores and since apple
is going to be releasing the m1x macbook
pros within the next two months it
doesn't make sense for the new macbook
air to come until next year and
according to minchiko this new macbook
air is launching in mid 2022
which perfectly lines up with apple's
wwdc event in june which would actually
be the perfect event to reveal the m2
chip since it's going to be two years
since apple announced the apple silicon
transition i also personally expect the
m2 chip to come with brand new
redesigned cores based on the new rv9
architecture and potentially be built on
a newer 4 nanometer process node from
tsmc and then i expect those exact cores
to be going into the a16 chip for the
iphone lineup so there you guys go those
were all of my conclusions on how apple
created the a15 chip and how it's
actually based on the same cores as the
m1 chip with some added improvements
like the faster neural engine and other
tweaks like that and if you totally
disagree with me then let me know down
in the comment section below but if you
enjoyed the video go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and watch one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]